[Music]
hey what's up guys it's rob and welcome
to my tutorial for thee people popular
in my last update video I asked you guys
whether you wanted to see the paper
popper or the ninja knot and although
the ninja knot came in first and I now
have a tutorial for you can find by
clicking this link right here a paper
popper was also pretty popular
maybe because that was the only other
choice but either way I'm going to teach
that huge now today all you're going to
need is a piece of printer paper the
good thing is it's the easiest thing I'm
going to probably teach you ever the
only tricky thing about it is getting it
to work and that's not even that tricky
so all you need to do is to grab a piece
of paper and let's get started however
you guys need to be sure that you don't
do it anywhere that's going to start
annoying people especially if they're
sleeping
ok so once you have your paper you want
to set it in the landscape orientation
meaning the longer ends are horizontal
just like my paper I'm going to be using
an eight-and-a-half by 11 which is
letter sized blue sheet I got it from
Staples it's the bright color so what
you want to do is to take the top of the
paper now and fold it down to the bottom
end and just align the edges for this
for the paper popper you don't have to
be as neat you know I'm used to saying
you know try to align it as best as
possible but if it's off a little bit
it's not going to matter also don't make
really sharp creases just kind of gently
run over it with your finger or you can
just push down on it the reason is you
can rip it if you crease it too much so
once you fold it you can unfold it then
you're going to take the top edge of the
paper again and fold it down to the
center line here
just fold it straight down there and
just make a crease okay so we took that
we folded it now we're gonna take this
top edge and we're going to fold it down
until it meets this edge of the paper
here so we're basically just gonna take
it and we're gonna fold it just like
that and then you make a crease on top
okay all right so now we have a little
bar here a little bar of the paper and
we're going to be taking this entire
thing this entire width of the paper and
we're going to fold it over on itself so
basically folding this at this line here
so just take the whole bar and we're
going to fold it once okay and then
we're gonna take the whole thing and
we're gonna fold it on itself one more
time okay thank you just push down on it
make sure it's nice and flat now at this
point you should have something that
looks like this and then we're going to
flip it over so now this bar is on the
back and we're going to fold it in half
this way so take this edge and fold it
across to this edge now the paper is
very rigid and straight right now so you
can just take your thumb and just kind
of push in the middle here and just
round it off a little bit it'll kind of
make it easier for you to fold it in
half so just take it line up the edges
and you can just hold it here and you
can just pull on that a lot of dust
particles around here
and just pinch that together there and
give it a nice crease so there you go
that's the paper popper
all right so to set it up to pop it what
you need to do is to hold it so that the
open ends are facing towards you like
this and so that the bar is on the left
side then you're gonna grab it here on
the little bar and you're also going to
grab the corner here what you're going
to do is you're going to pull upwards on
the bar and pull downwards or push
downwards on the corner here until you
see it's slide like this now once you
get it to slide you're going to grab
you're gonna grab these two corners here
this one and this one okay so pull down
grab these two corners and just pinch
them together like that all right now
this is the edge that you want to take a
look at a good rule of thumb to set the
popper off is to have this edge be at or
above these two corners of the paper
here okay
the lower you have it down the lower you
have this edge of the paper down the the
harder it will be to set it off but it
will also make a louder noise the lower
it is but if it's too low then you're
not going to be able to set it off at
all as you saw in my update video it
doesn't go off so I would say set it to
right about there or above and then what
you're gonna do is you're gonna
basically take it and you're gonna slam
it down just like this alright so once
you have it loaded just like this making
sure that this edge is at or above the
two corners of the paper right there
then you're ready to go now you'll
notice that these two little pockets
here are weird
air is going to be caught so you
basically just want to pretend that
you're going to throw it like a ball and
you want to try to catch the air in
there and you'll see that this whole
thing will basically pop out and then
from that point I'll show you how to
reload it so want to take it just hold
on to it really tight and just basically
throw it like you would for a ball that
now you'll notice that once you do that
you'll have something like this now to
reload it all you need to do is to fold
this edge of the paper down one time
okay and then again fold it back like
that and you're ready to go so again
take this edge and you're going to pull
down on the corner holding the bar here
okay once these corners of the paper go
past the edge then you can grab them
like that now if this edge is too low
like that then what will happen is it
just won't go off so what you do you
just lift it up slightly and there you
go now if the edge is too high then
it'll go off it just won't be very loud
so let's say it's like up here so it
makes kind of like a dull popping noise
but that's how it works
so again just pull it and you're ready
to go alright guys thank you very much
for watching the video it was a little
bit longer than I expected but I think
here not pretty well I had to explain a
lot of different ways to set it up and
stuff like that how to reload it I would
love to see some video responses with
your paper poppers down in the video
response section below leave me a
comment let me know what you thought of
the video what you might like to see
next I do know some paper planes and
stuff like that that I'd like to show
you guys they're pretty cool also as far
as popping is concerned I know how to do
something since I was a little kid well
not little maybe I was like
10 but I don't know if any of you guys
can do it but I don't know if I can even
teach how to do it either way it's this
popping with my tongue no I don't have
any gum no I'm not faking the noise with
the sound in the background or something
like that I've known how to do that for
a while basically you create a lot of
suction with your tongue rate comment
and if you're not already you can
subscribe by clicking the button up here
somewhere and I appreciate it